Mark: Okay. I'm going to start recording.
Bob: Oh shit. Balls balls balls balls balls.
Bob: Try to get it out before.
Mark: Nah it's fine it got caught in there you got your balls in my let's play
Bob: I got my balls caught in your recording
Mark: *Laughing*
Wade: You got YOUR balls in MY let's play
Bob: You got your let's play on my balls.
Mark: Wait a minute. *mouth noises* It's delicious. (laughing)
Wade: What is happening? Who's shooting it- why?
Wade: This is warm-ups / This is the starting area
Bob: This is
Bob: This is starter island for this game.
Wade: So this is - Okay. There's a starter island. That makes more sense.
Bob: You have no idea what you're doing, do you?
Mark: Yeah.
Wade: NO I DON'T! I've never played this, I've never seen this.
Mark: Alright, so same thing - map, you pick a space, you go there.
It's great. I suggest we go toOOOOOO
Ahh shit. I have no-
Bob: I mean there's gonna be bitches pretty much everywhere. We could try and go down to flush Factory.
Mark: Yeah, let's do that. Let's- let's definitely do that.
Wade: Oh, what are the buttons to... do that?
Mark: You space to jump- Bob: you push space to jump- Mark: like it says on the screen, WADE.
Bob: Okay, 3, 2, 1 go.
Mark: The- the- the parachuting glider mechanic is way different than in pubG, so
Bob: You can open and close your glider as much as you want. Mark: Yeah. Wade: Should I- you guys are going faster than me, should I open it?
Bob: You gotta like hold W, Wade.
Bob: Are you holding W? Wade: I am holding W.
Do I- Mark:  Are you pointin'?
Bob: Are you aiming where you want to go, Wade?
Mark: Well- well see the thing is the gliders-
Bob: No I was aimed up, like in-
Wade: I was aimed up like that other game.
Bob: No you don't have to aim up like that. Mark: The gliders got some- Bob: That ain't it.
Mark: It's- gliders got some bitchin horizontal-like movement. Like you can glide across the entire map if you wanted to.
Bob: Yeah a lot of people jump like-
immediately after you can, just to like glide to wherever the fuck. So there's a guy southeast of us.
I don't know if you see that guy.
Mark: I don't see that guy.
Wade: Yeah I see him, he's southeast of us.
Bob: He's got a- he's got a friend right up here with me.
Bob: I'm landing on the roof closest to ya, Mark
Mark: Yeah, cool
Wade (to Mark) You got a gun there?
Mark: Yeah, I do it's an (?)
Wade: Oh, there was another guy- there was another guy that was north of us.
Bob: Yeah, well it's squad. So there's probably like four-
Mark: Whoops,  wow that was a long fall. Whoop, wait hang on. Bob: Oh!
Bob: Oh my god, imma die.
Mark: Oh, no he got me! Wait! HELP. Get 'em!
Wade:  I'm coming!
Mark: AHHH!!
Mark: I got killed.
Mark: Finish him! Wade: Ahh beat him with the- Mark: Avenge me! Wade: Can I push you back?
Mark: God, I don't know how- Bob: I killed- I killed him. Mark:  Ah shit, I don't know how I got killed there that was really stupid of me.
Alright Bob:  Yeah, sorry. I thought you were like okay, but we fell through that roof- Mark: Yeah. Bob: I took like so much damage
Mark: Yeah, I did not expect that - I like lost all my health on that fall and
Mark: *groans*
Mark: and then, then like I- I- I
Mark: Should have just gone up behind him 'cause he didn't see me and I should've just gone up behind him
Mark: But I, shot him like a fool just to do a play-by-play of how much I sucked I hope this makes a lot of sense to you guys
Bob: Oh, I'm with you. Wade: Yeah. What the hell do we, uh, do now?
Mark: Okay- Bob:  Wade, you've played pubG, like a lot, like I know you have. Wade:  Yeah, but, I mean-
Bob: This is the same as that except it's just a different game. So you get guns- Mark: Yeah Bob: shoot at people with those guns-
Wade: Okay.
Bob: Oh fuck, you found the fucking thing without trying to find-
Wade: Oh, it was on the roof. / Mark: Oh yeah / Wade: I got blue juice
Mark: Yeah / Bob: Drink it / Mark: Drink that / Bob: It gives you shield /
Mark: Yeah, so there's chests and you can always hear 'em by the
Mark: *hrraauurrarrg* sounds.
Wade: That's true / Bob: Yeah, that's just like regular Fortnite. I remember that
Mark: *deep mhm*
Bob: My god is anybody else getting just like the worst performance ever right now?
Mark: No, I got you buttery smooth, baby.
Wade: No, no I always get good performance.
Bob: Janky and- oh it's cuz everything's on epic. Cool.
Mark: *odd unamused laughter*
Wade: Oh, yeah, all my settings are probably there, too. Mark: Oh, yeah, mine are, too, probably.
Bob: Medium / Mark: Let's go- let's go on... highhh
Let's do that.
Wade: So should I start harvesting materials or focus just on guns-
Bob: There are people here, so for now we should try and find chests and loot guns
Mark: I can't- I can't see the map so I have no idea where-
Bob: We should probably try and find these bitches to fight them and so we can just get like
mark back cuz...
Wade: Oh, can we get him back?
Bob: No, I mean just die and then get mark back.
Mark: Yeah, good luck. Good luck with you. I was a fool.
Bob: Life is meaningless without him.
Mark: Thank you! That's all I- ooh! Is that a guy? Bob:  There's a guy over here by me, Wade. / Okay, I'm comin'.
Bob: There's another guy to the right right outside to the right to the right to the right shoot him
Bob: Shoot him, Wade.
Wade: Oh, this is first fire.
Bob: Please shoot him.... continue shooting him.
Mark: ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Mark: You guys really cocked it up didn't ya you really boned it.
Bob: I killed the guy that killed you
Mark: *slow laughter*
Bob: I'm just saying that's pretty cool.
Mark: Whatever. I'm just saying. I'm not saying I didn't cock it up. I'm just saying that you guys also cocked it up.
Mark: Together we're like three cocks in a blanket. You know like just...
Bob: The cockiest blanket that's ever cocked.
Mark: Cocking it up all over the place just-
Mark: Slammin' our sli- Yeah. / Bob: Oh, that's a good sound yeah. / Mark: Thank you.
Bob: That's what I like /Mark: alright cool. Cool cool. /Wade: That is good.
Wade: That is pretty good.
Mark: Yeah. I hope that gave the proper illusion of the cocks and the blanket that we are
Mark: Hey wait, why did it turn me to the asian guy?
Mark: You guys seeing this?
*collective hmms*
Mark: Something- /Wade: Maybe it knows something we don't
Mark: *laughter*
Mark: The biggest secret of our collective lives is that I've been Asian this whole time *more laughter*
Wade: *gasp* What?!
Mark:I know I know I mastered-
Wade: Take that back! / Mark: It's true. You know it-
Wade: NO! /  Mark: Look into your heart,
Mark: you know it to be true.
Wade: No!
Mark: Alright. Where are we going?
Wade: I don't know.
Bob: I like tomato town.
Mark: alright, let's go to tomato town.
Let's do this / Jump right now to Tomato Town, my friends
Alright you got it, I'm going / Like right now? / Hopefully this time we-
Like I'm already gone, baby
We landed in a- we landed in a place that didn't have any of our
uhhhhhhh... our...
allies in it, so HOPEfully, hopefully this time we'll actually get some buddies of ours
OHHH, baby, baby, baby. / Okay there's- there's two- yeah
There's two other people coming down. I don't know if they're our teammate, we won't be able to tell
Circle back for that brick house on the- there, they're going- oh, woah, oh no- they just-
Oh, there's a guy- one of them is going to the brick house
Shit! Okay. Uh, welp good luck everybody I guess
I don't know what we're gonna do- / Are we still going to the brick-? / I dOn'T kNoW / Just no- just land together. Just land- why are we going to the brick house?
(?) i'm here
Okay, I think they might have been our teammates because it seems like we got some people here / They're our teammates I see Green Arrows over them- / awesome awesome awesome
Awesome. Awesome. Okay. / Oh yeahhh, that's / So-
yeah, we're with our teams
They're our teammates or they're really clever enemies who painted green arrows over their heads, and they're like
"wAiT" / Yeah- *laughing*
"wait..." / *laughing*
In like a minute they're just gonna be like
"Alright fuck 'em" / *laughing* "fuck em! Literally fuck em! Now!" / "Don't kill him. Just whip your dicks out!"
*laughing yet again*
Is that what this 50/50 mode's all about?
Yeah, man / Yeah, it's, uh-
50/50 on whether you're gonna get fucked... / Yeah pretty much / ...is the full title that they didn't tell you about / yeah
There's no real way to like sugarcoat it, / Okay I like our allies, but they took all our stuff. / I got guns
Why didn't you get guns? I've got A gun and it's... not good. / Yeah I have like a common pistol. / I got a pistol and a shotgun.
I've got a common this / that's okay. We can move on where's the circle gun okay?
actually
We're in a good place cuz we are right where the circle is gonna be
So keep an eye out 'cause then there might be a horde of like enemies coming to this town
But there also might be a horde of allies / I didn't even hear any chests
Were there chests? / Uh, I didn't hear any / They've all been opened as far as I can tell / huhh
Well / We could go over to brick house, I guess. I think someone did that too, though
Yeah / Yeah they did / So where do we wanna move to?
Well / We could go to Wailing Woods
OooOoh, great. Well, to the south of here are some mines that sometimes have stuff in it
But they seem to be swarming that I'm gonna go over to brick house- just see if there's anything that was like looked over
Kay, we're gonna head south
No, I'm going over to Mark, Wade. /  Okay. There's a tactical shotgun right here whoever needs it, yeah
Yeah, usually like / That guy hasn't finish looting it yet? / It's it's there's one in there in that door / It's probably just like a regular
It's probably just not oh. It's a green. I guess it's not horrible. / Yeah
I got three grenades / People sometimes pass over stuff easily. I'm gonna see if there's anything hidden in the roof / Do we need building materials? / Yeah, so you collect building materials by
Smashing stuff up and you build things
Obviously / I just didn't know if we needed them in this mode / Yes / Yeah, you're gonna want- you're gonna want a pretty good supply of building materials
Yeah, so wood, all sorts of shit, brick- like, once you get good at building like you're very fast about it
I usually set up my, uh, my wall to be a windowed wall right away
Hey, our friends are engaging. You guys wanna come help?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I only got a pistol and a shotgun
I've got a submachine gun, but it's suppressed. / Oh yeah, I see you- wait.  / I'm gonna push
I'm gonna push this way. / I'm building something real quick. / I'm, uh, running with Bob
Okay / I assume there's no reviving people in this / Yes, there is / you can get them up like pubG, but you can't like revive
Behind me Bob. / Yeah, you shooting that guy? / Where? / There's a guy close- there's a guy close right there, Mark.
Woah, woah- I didn't know you guys were over there
Okay that guy's dead on the hill. / Oh my god. There's so many enemies over here
Yeah/ I'm- I'm running away. I'm gonna die. / Get- get back to my fortification right here
Yeah, I'm gonna run back to Mark, Wade. / Build walls behind you as you run
And it'll- it'll help like just with, you know, not dying. / Oh fuck!
Ah! Help. Build around me. / I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming. / They're pushing me!
AHHH! / Oh no, they're- yeah, they're def- Oh my god. Y-y-you're boned. Yeah, you're boned.
Sorry, you're- you're very boned / Well... cool.
AhhAHh! NOOOOO!
Remember me!
I got one- I got one down. Where are the other ones?
*singing I Will Survive*
Oh my god, there's three more coming over that hill. Oh my god. / Whoa whoa whoa whoa? Whoa? Whoa? Whoa? Ah shit didn't see those guys
Oh my god, those guys just like fucking swarmed us
Yeah, that's what happens like if the whole team is there then it's just oh, it's just carnage
No! Wade, no! / Wade, are you still alive? / No! / No, you're- / Finish him! / OooooOOoOoOh
Shiiitt dude
*lots of laughing and screaming*
Seven enemies are just like... "woah, what's this guy doing over here?" / *laughing*
"You just laying there, buddy?"
Alright, I'll go back
Yeah, but you can see like you can see like the fun of the game
So I would recommend like when things like that happen definitely
uh
Hauling back and just- / Don't charge in / just fortifying
Bob you were a lovely pink lady for like a split second, and then you went like you switched to an asian person
I was like, I was bae penny
Yeah, let's, uh, maybe go to
retail row
Okay, that's a little bit further well a little- little bit
Nah, we can get there / Well, no that's good. It's good
it's further because it means less people / yeah something like that seems like everyone automatically just jumps to the very first town and
*laughing*
Oh, we're jumping. Jump, Wade. / Oh, I pressed F
crap
*laughing* PubG loser / I gotta get used to this
Which one of these things is retail row okay, it's this / the big- / yeah the far one / ...one
We got other people coming to retail row / I hope they're friends / there's a lot of 'em
I'm gonna land on like the right side over here. / I'm gonna. Yeah, right side
Yeah, I'm gonna be in like the second building on the right / yeah, second building
I'm gonna go for the roof short of the basketball court. Is that the one you guys are going for / ...Wait
Yeah, yeah, yeah / Teammates here! / Teammates! Ah, Hell yeah.
I'm gonna go further then, I'm gonna go back here.
You're not a teammate / Uh oh
You okay? / there's a non-teammate here / Run! Run before they get a gun / he's in this house. I'm-
I'm above him, but I'm trying to GTFO
Wait oh I found a chest
No, this mine. Get the fuck off of my stuff. That's right fuck off. You asshole. Alright. Where are you guys?
I'm coming / I went further / I'm west of you
I'll be there soonish
Man these guys cleaned this place oUT
Where's the enemy? Where's that enemy guy? / He- he was in this house. I haven't seen him- ah! Hi friend
Enemy, enemy where? I'm in / No, no, no he's a friend. He's a friend. There's an actual friend. / Okay. / Oh
Just the way he said friend made it sound like- / Yeah *laughter* / HI FRIEND / He walked around the corner pointing a gun at-
No give me a- come on bud. Man, this guy's taking all the guns and shit
I don't know how you drop anything or else like when I find something. I would give it to you
I only have one gun though, so / I think you can drag it out of your inventory when you're when you're holding alt but
I'm fine. I'm gonna push further in towards Wade, then. / We're doing surprisingly well / I got a friend over here with me, right now
Yeah, we've got a lot of teammates in this area, so this is actually fortuitous / Whoo, that is stressful
You don't get to know if they're teammates when you're dropping though, so you're kind of like- *stressful noises* / yeah
Oh! Seven teammates, thank God / yeah exactly, right?
What a stroke of luck / I could be dead or it's just teammates. I do hear shooting. Or running / Yeah, I do too
I'm not 100% sure where / sounds like it's coming from... the west?
It seems like we're winning because we just killed a few of them, but / Yeah / Yeah, they weren't Jimmy poop holes
Not Jimmy poop holes
my favorite poop hole
*laughing* / Alright I got a gun, thank God
Good I don't have a lot of ammo, but I got some gun I'm gonna meet up with you guys
I'm I'm nearest Wade, so that's where I'm headed. Alright, you guys find anything else?
No guns, I'm harvesting up (?)- / I got a chest, but the chest only had a white m16 in it
That's fine, an m16 is a really good gun. In my opinion it's the best just because it's like balanced and
Good range shit blah blah blah dick a tree yada yada / What, is that the car exploding? That beeping noise
Yeah, when you harvest a car it like like a car alarm goes off
Okay, I guess I'll just keep loading up on bricks and stuff. / Where's the circle? / It's right
Yeah, it's right on top of us. Yeah, and lots of allies is good
What'd that car ever do to you?
Kill it! / Fuck that car / Alright, I've got a- I've got a good bit of metal. / What's a good bit?
I haven't played this game in so long
I've got like 200. 200 usually is a good number cuz there- everyone else also has a bajillion things
I can just let my team carry me
you're saying / yeah
Pretty much / this town has been scavenged
to all Hell so / Yeah, uh, Bob, Mark and I are toward the west side of town now
We got more teammates coming up from the west side as well
Looks like we're converging the big team this might be this might be good for us. / Yeah, I see four guys west side coming
Like north west of town and you guys have five guys trailing you right now plus me / If you guys need
They're all out here in the wilderness / If you guys need smg's there's some smg's over here
I would like that just to have like more bullets to shoot / yeah
'cause all I have is one gun still
They're still in this- / Are they like right on you right now?
Yeah, usually actually what will happen is
uh
Teammates are actually pretty nice about this
They will drop guns that they don't need / There's, um, there's an SMG, a pistol, and an m16 here Bob. I took one of the SMG's.
I might take an SMG / Okay, our guys are pushing north. / Where are you at right now? / I was just on the roof / Oh, you're right next to me.
He was in that house that we were at
Yeah, I was just checking the roof to make sure no one got it, but someone did... of course. It's 39 to 27
They've lost a good bit of people so it looks like we're gonna have the advantage.
By no doing of our own! / Good
Yeah / Yeah / We're good!
Hey, we- we landed.
*laughter* yeahhhh
I have 200 stone AND wood / Niiiccee / Look at all these boots on the grouuunnddd
There's so many boootsss
*laughing*
Did you see the new Brian Regan special? / That's from his new one, right? / Yeah, oh god I love it. / I have not / It's really funny
I just don't think I've ever seen a Brian Regan anything / Really? Ohhh man / You are not mY FRIEND ANYMORE
WoaAAHHH
Alright, well I'll just go this way / Alright then
You should just watch Brian Regan
Oh shit, someone shooting someone / It's the guy on top of that, uh, building in the depot
I'm sure the depots been claimed and like tall heck
But I'll run through it just to see / but which who is he shooting who / yeah, I see like built
uh
Stuff all over the place / There's dudes up in there. / Ohhh / Man, it's hard to get loot in this shit
If you land near enemies, you die. If you land near your friends like nope there's nothing left anywhere
*laugh*
have fun with your
There's more submachine guns in here. Do you get more ammo if you pick up more submachine guns?
Uh, I don't think so
I think each one comes with one clip in it
But I don't know if that counts as more ammo for you to like reload into your other gun, so / Yeah / Yeah
Alright, it looks like the engagement is happening north for some reason. They must have all gone to Anarchy Acres
That's my only guess. / Oh, we're in the... new circle, though. We're on the- / Oh yeah. We're on the cusp
Yeah, I'm gonna go over here and see if they're coming because if they are in Anarchy Acres they're gonna be all charging from the north
What the hell is that?
That's the storm. / That's a drop, no that- / Oh!
*odd noise*
Behind us if you look at 195 there's like a balloon, that's like a care package. / Oh, they do have drops in this game
AaAaHhH! That's so nice!
Mostly, I think the care packages in this game are like this- uh, building materials
But I think they do also spit out like a gun or some blue juice or something / That'd be nice
Sometimes / Yeah, I don't like being without a shield out here, but- oh do you need some? Oh? No you- whoa /
Whoa
Where are we at? Someone's shooting
What? What are you shoot-? / The sky / Woah
What if we just-
What the fuck?! / Whoa, what the- / You can shoot the balloon and make the care package drop faster. / Ohhh
Oh my god, guys- / Ohhh
Iggy Azalea was in our room. / THE Iggy Azalea? / THE.
THE Ziggy. / Who the hell is Ziggy? Why don't I know things? / I don't know.
I'm not culturally like- / that wasn't- / significant is not the word
Everyone's rallying to the balloon. Wait what the fuck I just saw- / I'm not culturally relevant. How do I know things?
Yeah, everyone's rushing south. I don't know why.  / Let's do it. / Oh, we're down 30. Oh my god
Our team is dropping like flies all of the sudden. / Yeah, I-
They must be going for the balloon. / Don't worry. We'll get there after it's all over.
We were up like 39 to 24, weren't we? /  Yeah
Yeah, they're here. They're here
And building walls, so just start random spam building is that what you're saying? / I mean if you want yeah, that's it's definitely a strategy
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Oh Jesus Christ / Whoa / What?! / They seem to have rocket launchers. / Yep. That they do. Okay, they're
Yeah, they're building up a storm on the other side over there
I think they got the balloon, which means they probably got the heavy ordinance / Well, that's our team right there. / Whoa, there's a bush.
Yeah, the- / there's a bush back- / Woah, whoa whoa whoa. Yeah, whoo these guys are trying real hard.
I'm a field oh for God's sake get the revive. I'm a field medic
OOooOh
Oh, that's my building you just snip sniped. / Oh my god these revives take forever. / Yeah these snipers are no jok- ow!
Owie owie owie these snipers are not joking around here
No they're not
Why don't we ever find- / Oh shit! I just got sniped! / Okay, coming coming coming
Coming. Which direction, do you know? / I don't know. I've got walls around me though, I'm fairly safe. / Okay.
I don't know where that came from though. I got bandages. / I got you.
No one built a door in this thing
I've got a med kit. Is there a way I could drop it for you?
Uh, let me- here- let me / I think you hold alt and try and like drag it out of your inventory you can drop it
But I don't know. / Here, let me- let me-  I can- / Here you go, Bob. Are you on me? / Yeah. I know there's- / Oh yeah, thank you.
Yeah, either one of those is good.  Uh, I'll keep- / I'll use this. / Okay. Jesus Christ. Yeah, this is where it gets scary. It's a fucking war zone. Yeah. / Oh my God.
Yes
Jesus Christ
This is like a world war two battle scene in the form of a hilarious looking cartoon. / Yeah, I was gonna say
The whole world is like *explosion noise*
Fall bitch fall bitch fall bitch fall bitch. YEAHAHAHA got one. He was building a staircase to nowhere and I just blasted him. / Are they all south of us?
Yeah, they're all south
Not enough ammo? Oh I had the wrong gun out this whole time?! / Guys- guys are using-
Guys are using my stairs
OW! OOH OOH OOH! OW!
You all right you all right? / I got snip sniped from uh- / Yep, that'll happen. Alright. Okay. You guys believe in me?
Because I've got an insane strategy that I do sometimes. You guys want to follow my lead?
Uhhh
You ready? / I'm just having fun existing and being alive, but okay.
I'm just what I do is I just run and I build walls in front of me, and I just kind of like create this
Ah shit! Someone's hitting me from- ah! From my left from my left. Where the hell did that come from? / They're way to the left
Oh jeez. OH jeez. I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead. Ah shit!
They're- they're- yeah, they're definitely on the left in the trees I believe. / Oh, oh there was a sniper shooting me.
Yeah, those are the guys that are picking all of our- yeah, I'm all the way dead. Yeah, somewhere to the left
farther left than those guys
I knocked one down! / Yeahh! Yeah you knocked him good! / Nice BOB!
Nice nice nice nice nice. / I am out of good ammo. / That's all right. There's a lot of corpses in the field
I'm gonna move up to our Allies' position. / Oh I knocked someone down! Yeahh! / Yeah, Wade. Good shit, Wade.
Damn. These- these- these- the other team really pulled it out of their ass to get this like underway like wow
holy shit. / We're losing right now! / I want inside!
Yeah, I don't know how that happened, but they really really pulled it together. / God these snipers are so snipey / Yeah
It's the people in the trees to the left. I know that for a fact
Yeah, oh shit. Oh god. They're fucking- it's the apocalypse in here! / Ooh hoo hoo hoo hoo
All right, you guys got this! / OH WHAT?!
UH OH
I just think I just took a- that was a pistol!?
Yeah
*screams*
OH GOD! / Those are definitely rockets! / Come in here, Wade. Come in here. I got you, I got you. / *Mark laughing*
Ah a true- / That's not a pistol! / A true friend, a true friend.
This is awful! / *laughing*
Cover me (?)
This is so chaotic! I fucking love this! / I KNOW, RIGHT?
'Cause, you'll get like shitty matches where you die like right away, but then you'll get the matches that are just like
*SCREAMING* / NO IM TRYING TO FINISH HIM!
I'm trying to build us one more cover. Okay? / Oh look at all that ammo that guy dropped. Oh tempting Wade, right?
*screaming* HEY HEY I DID THAT
*Mark laughing*
Where's their ammo? I need ammo so bad right now.
All over the field but good luck getting out there. / *screams*
WADE I BUILT THAT WALL. I BUILT THAT WALL. / I'M GOING TO IT / I BUILT THAT WALL *laughing*
YEAHHAHA! / Seeeee
Mark protected me! / I did even in death. I protected you.
I feel VERY secure right now. / *laughing*
I'm coming, Wade. Don't worry. / Wait, if you- wait, look behind you look behind you there's a
series of walls that I built to get to that point you see how that goes? / Hey Wade, how's it going?
Yeah I do
*mixture of screaming and laughing*
Oh no, guys! Behind us! / WE NEED REPAIRS!!!
We needed the tools! / I think you guys are done for. You guys are done for.
It's okay, Bob. I'm behind wall #2!
Wow, who's-? / Oh, Bob, you're down?! / Who's the hell is building?
Wow- oop, welp. / Ohhh, we're gonna die now. / Oh yeah, there- ahhhh
Not by shi- shi- shi- shoo- What is his name? / Sie_tv you inn-alliterate... idiot. / *mark laughing*
No! That's not who killed me.
It was Chikyperrito or something.
WATCH YOUR LANGUAGE!
*laughing* / What?!
eXcUsE yOu
There are seven of us alive, but they're like- / Yeahh. Oh geez. Wow. Yeah, they flanked the shit out of us
*collective woahs and laughing*
Oh no. / Is all of our team that's alive, down?
I think there's one guy still at the depot / There are two guys still operating.
Yeah, we- what we should have done is we should have probably fortified the depot itself that would have been smart
Bucky bots has this don't even worry about it. / Yeah, Bucky bot built like- it was already up there
Fully fortified. / Oh hell yeah.
Oh boy. Oh shit. Oh, he's gonna explode now. / Bucky bot is doomed. :(
You got this Buckybots! They're- they're just gonna slowly destroy your entire fucking place.
*laughing*
Let's see what's going on with Tenable Acorn. Ah, I see. / Get him, Fuap! Yeah, Fuap knocked out RandisBobandis.
TenableAcorn is just hiding in a bush.
What a bitch.
*sighs* that's funny
Oh, they're down though, okay.
Yeah, they're down, they're down.
We got Fuap. Oh shit. That's scary. / Get 'em, Fuap. / Get him, Fuap. Get him.
Oh shit. Oh miss miss miss. Oh sweet misses. Oh too many misses. Ah, and dead. Alright, just Buckybots.
One b12 Buckybots. / You got this Bucky Bobo. / You will be forever immortalized
or everyone will immediately forget that all
Oh, no. That's a shitty show
Oh great, Dirtfeet won. / Dirtfeet!
Chickyperrito was their name.
Yeah, I can't believe they turned that around that is it very impressive
That was bad. / Yeahh.
*dope outro music plays*